eswatini is africa's last absolute
monarchy
but the pro-democracy protesters who've
been taken to the streets there
wants kenyam swati the third to change
that and soon
protesters have clashed with police for
days demanding democratic reforms
in the kingdom formerly known as
swaziland swatini is a small mountainous
state between south africa
and mozambique though the government and
the opposition give
different figures they both agree that
dozens died at the hands of security
forces
in the ensuing crackdown the terminal
prompted the government to impose tight
restrictions on their population
partly justified on the grounds of the
fight against the coronavirus pandemic
but the measures including school
closures and a curfew
only seemed to heighten tensions
shops and businesses set on fire
chaos on the streets roads blocked and
stores looted
these were the scenes as anger boiled
over among protesters calling for
democracy
in eschatini we are the youth of
swaziland
and we are so much depressed by the
government
gangster ramos
[Music]
the one man he's talking about is king
maswati the third
he's ruled espartini for more than three
decades as an absolute monarchy
appointing the prime minister and
retaining the ultimate power
the king is known for his lavish
lifestyle and 15 wives
he's also been accused of repressing any
opposition
but there's growing demand for change us
as young people of the land
we don't want the king to be part of the
government and if we want to be part of
the government
he must first be citizen like the rest
of us
and go to work like every one of us so
the reason why the people
are in the lair of the country on the
streets making sure that the business
operations of the land until we attain
freedom
many of the businesses targeted in the
latest wave of protests have links to
the royal family
eswatini's government imposed a curfew
and called for calm
we are a nation that believes in
dialogue
and it is with that in mind that we once
again request
all our creative massage to use
alternative channels to express their
credences
garmin has opened an email address
where maswati can continue to direct
their concerns and petitions
security forces were sent in to deal
with the unrest and opposition groups
say several dozens of protesters were
killed
the un has called the crackdown deeply
concerning
amid a tense calm there are fears there
could be more bloodshed to come
my next guest spent a year behind bars
in swatini jail
for contempt of court after he
criticized swaziland's judicial system
amnesty international declared him a
prisoner of conscience
introducing their prominent human rights
lawyer thulani maseko
hello sir thanks for joining us you are
the chair of the multi-stakeholders
coordinating
team an umbrella group what do you
represent or who do you represent and
what exactly are you calling for
thank you the group represents
all the political parties of swaziland
there's about servant of political
parties currently
in in the group we also represent the
multi-you know
structural psychological
the organization people uh and the
rest of the groupings in switzerland who
are calling for change
the simple call that we are making as a
is the transition of the country into a
multi-party
dispensation under a democratic
constitution
where the monarchy shall be clearly
defined in that new constitution
one key issue is that protesters have
a challenge with the king and the power
he wields
some want him to step down what do you
expect him to do
there is no call as yet for the king to
step down
there is a call for him to declare
you know a commitment to engage
in a process of dialogue it is that
process
which will determine the future of the
monarchy in the country
right now there are some voices which
are saying even the
mayhem and the and the question and the
brutal murder
of people by the army there are those
who are saying perhaps the time
has come to consider whether in future
the place for the monarchy wasn't so at
the moment there's no call for him to
step down
for a call for him to make a clear
commitment to the cause of dialogue
immediately by the turkey through saturn
so thousands of people are already dead
is there any sort of compromise on a
solution that will not endanger the
lives of pro-democracy protesters
well the situation is so regrettable
uh the the people continue to be
endangered by the
army on the streets who also
go on to invade their private homes you
know
to brutalize them to name them
to break their bones and bodies hence
the clear call
that the army must be removed from the
streets
to stop beating and hurting our people
and
allow an environment to be conducive for
the dialogue in that
that's what you want that's what you
want but if that is not
exactly the case at least immediately
what kind of compromise can you reach to
ensure that no one else loses their
lives in this protest
no compromise has been thought of at the
moment
the call is clear that the
troika has to ensure that the process
they've started give results to
a new dispensation where
the people enjoy the right to form a
government
so what role can the international
community play in all of this
as you understand right now his majesty
is unwilling to open the doors
to negotiations he appealed there to
make
sadaq to the au to the un
and all internal bodies is for them
to prevail for his majesty
open the doors for dallas there is no
other way
which the christ can be resolved rather
than sitting down
in our diversity and conceive and craft
a way forward for the country that is
our call to the
world to intervene here and persuade
these measures to see that there is more
wisdom
sitting down and talking as opposed to
arms on the defenseless and unarmed
people of swaziland mr masako you were
jailed simply for criticizing the
judicial system
seven years later things look worse than
ever do you sometimes lose hope
that things will ever change we can
never ever
we can never ever lose hope and never
ever give up
on the bright future for the people of
switzerland
we can never at one moment you know
think that
we remain under these conditions there
must be something
new for the people of the country and
the world must assist
us in every manner possible to ensure
that those who are not willing to engage
are forced to engage in a dialogue
to take the county forward tulane masako
human rights lawyer and chair of the
multi-stakeholders coordinating team
thanks for your time thank you so much
thank you very much